this is the first interview that we're
actually getting allowed to share things
so i'm so excited oh my goodness i like
bawled my eyes out reading the script
kane i was like have you read this
episode yet
no i am not okay
it was so cute
[Music]
summer's over and the babysitter's club
is officially back in business season
two of babysitter's club was so amazing
i laughed i cried i'm just so glad that
it's back goodbye my claudia momona i've
got to give you so many props because
the mimi episode was so incredible it
was so heartbreaking to see that she
passed away but it was so beautiful to
see claudia's grieving journey and
bringing in her japanese heritage what
was your reaction to that script when
you first read it oh my goodness i like
bawled my eyes out reading the script um
it's really beautifully written i'm just
so thankful to like you know be being
able to like tell that story i think
it's very interesting to see how claudia
kind of you know handles and like how
she kind of copes with the situation and
for example like stacy like she was
always there for her which i think
claudia's very grateful for and the
script itself is just so beautiful and
i'm so happy that we were able to
incorporate a lot of you know japanese
traditions into the episode
the only one who's been here for me has
been ashley so what you're so grateful
to her you're giving her mimi's jewelry
not grateful to her i'm in love with her
she's my girlfriend claudia i screamed
out of excitement when we found out that
janine and ashley were actually a couple
this is a new layer to janine that we
didn't get in the bsc books how are you
feeling about this amazing inclusion
storyline i think the bsc what's so
special about it is how like inclusive
it is
and you know being able to tell that
story as well is just it's it's
something i'm just so proud to be a part
of i want your kids to be my kids like
for real like adoption
one of my personal favorites is in the
finale when we see that watson wants to
adopt christy and all of her brothers
sophie what was your reaction to that
sweet reveal oh my gosh when i read that
script on the airplane to canada i
started crying on the airplane and
vivian who plays mallory was sitting
right next to me and she was like are
you okay and i was like have you read
this episode yet no i am not okay
it was so cute and it's like honestly
just the most heartwarming thing and
filming it was so cute i just
i'm so excited for everyone to see it
stacy hey
i was hoping it's you shay we saw in
season two that stacy has a lot going on
she's still learning to manage her
diabetes her parents are fighting a lot
what is one aspect of stacey's storyline
that you're most excited for young girls
to see of course still keeping it very
realistic with her struggles with
diabetes but i think it's also really
great to see that she still has family
struggles too that is a very normal
thing to have as a teenager and i think
a lot of people watching at home will be
able to relate to that aspect of her as
well because like obviously there are
other characters who whose parents are
divorced um they're going through
seeing their parents get remarried all
that kind of stuff but i think it's
great to show stacy struggling with it
in that moment and the awkwardness and
the tension um so i'm excited for people
to watch that at home because i know
it's a very real thing
so are you guys like fully boyfriend and
girlfriend now i don't know
you haven't talked since and i can't
malia how about you what marianne moment
are you most excited for fans to see in
season two marianne
what spoilers do we get to share with
her ah this is the first interview that
we're actually getting allowed to share
things so i'm so excited i feel like
with marianne i'm really excited to see
how the episode of her and logan pulls
off but she also is kind of that advice
teller and that sense of comfort
throughout a lot of the girls you know
with claudia and then with sophie and
christy at the end um talking about her
dad and then talking about mimi so
they're just those things that i'm
excited to have marianne be that kind of
nurturing soul in that comfort side that
we didn't get to see throughout the
first season because she was usually the
one that's crying she says sorry all the
time um so i'm just excited for you guys
to see that part oh dawn you look super
tan three weeks in southern california
where the sunshine is advertised
i feel like a whole new person kendra
which spoiler meant the most to you in
season two what are you most excited for
fans to see well in season one dawn was
all good with everything she you know
had her life put together and she never
got upset and then in season two you
really see her bottle up all of her
emotions until she kind of just explodes
and i think it's really you see how she
handles um having anxiety all the girls
struggle through something and this is
specifically what dawn struggles with
and i think it's really important to see
that for other people who might be
struggling with anxiety to see that like
you know they're not alone and there's
other people that have it and struggle
with it
and you just really get to see her
handle that that was like clockwork
smoothest silk a well-oiled machine
you guys are awesome if we do get a
third season what is something that you
would love to see for your character
next to the end what would you like to
see from mallory if we get another
chapter i would definitely like to see
more of her family more of her family
life i think we got to see a little bit
this season but that's one of my hopes
for season three and we're keeping our
fingers crossed i loved filming all the
ballet scenes so much this season you
saw jessie and how she was a background
character in her school performance and
how she's trying to accept that that
she's not the lead anymore i hope and
fingers crossed for season three we
would get to see jesse actually be the
lead in a performance i've read some of
the jessie books and she has such cool
characters a lot i know she plays
sleeping beauty in one of the books i
think that'd be really cool to do
didn't you just come from ballet that
was class tonight i have rehearsals for
the fall showcase i think just
continuing kind of claudia's journey i
would love to see
how she continues to cope with like the
loss of her grandmother it'll be
interesting to see like what problems
she faces that may have been affected by
that situation as well i'm just very
excited to explore more if we get
another season apparently shay how about
you what do you want to see for stacey
anything at all would be amazing but
like we were discussing earlier with her
family issues i think it's just it's a
very real issue and i think it would be
great to have that portrayed in this
show in a deeper way as well that is a
really good question i don't think i
thought about that you know i really
hope if we have another season they
include christy's crushers her softball
team i really hope they do that as you
know in season one don's parents are
divorced and i would love to see her
spend time with her family spend time
with her brother and her dad maybe go to
california
she's a california girl at heart and it
would just mean a lot to me if she gets
to spend more time with her family yeah
and maybe bring marianne with her
definitely
and malia what do you want to see from
marianne honestly a cat that is all
enough
she has a cat tigger in the books he's a
kitten he's striped i've been reading
about that cat since before i could read
and oh my god i just i'm desperately
wanting it if there is a third season
but who knows you know whatever happens
i'm grateful nonetheless it's been a
journey and i'm so grateful to be part
of it being a part of the babysitter's
club means we show up for each other
i love a bff club
[Music]